alors le coup de coeur du grenier à sel
pour le mois de mai se portent sur un
film magnifique c'est un film français
qui fait maintenant partie du patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco qui a été réalisé
par le grand marcel carné et l'immense
poète jacques prévert qui est un succès
fabuleux
dès sa sortie en salles au lendemain de
la seconde guerre mondiale en 1945 qui
est aussi porte à l'écran par deux
acteurs très talentueux qui sont arletty
et jean louis barrault ce film est connu
aussi pour avoir montré les coulisses du
théâtre est mis en valeur l'art du
pantomime
vous l'aurez deviné il s'agit des
enfants du paradis le film de marcel
carné dans sa version complète en deux
actes d'une durée de 3 heures 10
bienvenue au cinéma le grenier à sel
rendez vous le vendredi 12 mai à 20h45
attention c'est une séance unique bon
film bonne projection
[Musique]